hey folks welcome back we're really
excited about this award right here on
the table now I told you about this a
few weeks ago but wanted to show it to
you this sits behind Dave in his studio
normally I snuck in and I stole it
during the break but I'm gonna put it
back relax this is awesome it's because
of you great people unbelievable here
comes Dave he's excited about it too
look have you ever seen so excited of
all the awards that's the one he runs
out 400,000 subscribers that's what
that's for and we're loving the
community here so thanks to you people
and we call you the YouTube crazies i'm
actually watching the chat right here
everybody is loving that the dave
appearance very fun so hey stay with
this subscribe and share because the
community is growing and we thank you
for that hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27,000
well you've got a fifty-thousand-dollar
income or five hundred thousand dollar
income
you